et bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6 et
mélissa mollen dupuis cette semaine on a
une question de windeck on va l'écouter
d'ailleurs moi je veux savoir s'il ya
des services au niveau montréal et qui
servent les autochtones alors lindsay me
demande si et des services qui existe à
montréal pour les premières nations
oui on appelle ça les centres des
meetings est d'ailleurs aussi des
centres qui sont qui sont utilisés qui
sont connus pour ce qui est des
questions d'une vielle itinérant
souliers aux femmes sont victimes de
violences mais pour en connaître un peu
plus sur justement les violences dont
sont victimes les premières nations les
nations autochtones
je pense que tu peux aller vers des
commissions comme la commission vérité
réconciliation que beaucoup servi à
éclairer justement les québécois et les
canadiens sur les réalités et sur
l'histoire du canada par rapport aux
pensionnats par exemple et qui explique
dans le fond un peu la base de beaucoup
d autres réalités des programmations
je pense aussi qu'on vient d'avoir la
commission vient c'est on a aussi
présentement le bureau d'enquêté
indépendant qui a maintenant un agent de
liaison autochtone donc des fois les
ressources vont venir de chez vous mais
c'est surtout l'intérêt qui est très
nouveau qui vient justement du grand
courant de réconciliation et que des
fois ça peut être difficile parce que
les violences on s'en rend pas compte
ça peut être aussi quand on décide
d'ignorer les questions qui touchent les
premières sont donc je te remercie
beaucoup lui nous d'avoir posé la
question
c'est à dire que ton intérêt est ouvert
et justement tu vas avoir l'oeil
beaucoup plus alerte quand tu vas voir d
injustice quand tu vas entendre des
histoires sur les femmes assassinées et
disparues ou sur dans son la sur
représentation des enfants à la dpj pour
les programmations
je pense que ça c'est déjà une partie de
la solution c'est d'avoir le public
québécois intéressés à ces réalités là
donc merci beaucoup pour ta question
en espérant que j'ai pu y répondre
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer s'il vous
plaît n'hésitez pas surtout à partager
les vidéos passé une belle semaine